president Trump's pledged to invest a
trillion dollars in infrastructure made
no mention of our country's outdated
rail system and track is planning a
summer of urgently needed upgrades those
improvements will lead to more delays
and cancellations at the nation's
busiest train hub New York's Penn
Station Peter Greenberg is on a train
from Philadelphia to New York with why
our passenger rail service has struggled
for decades
Peter good morning good morning it might
be hard to believe but 2017 marks the
53rd birthday of the high-speed bullet
train service in Japan
Amtrak which was created 46 years ago
has struggled since it began service
decades of insufficient funding and
infrastructure investment have left
America's passenger rail network lagging
behind most of the developed world for
over a century railroads with a backbone
of America trains move people between
cities and provided Freight Transport
for industry but by the mid 20th century
competition from interstate highways and
Airlines forced many railroads out of
business in 1971 Amtrak was established
as America's passenger rail service but
from day one it was plagued with
problems it still hasn't solved most
routes never made a profit and in many
cases Amtrak doesn't even own the tracks
there's about a hundred and fifty trains
on the whole Northeast Corridor Stephen
Gardner overseas planning for Amtrak in
order to run fast frequent reliable
passenger trains you really need to
build a system for for just that a
dedicated a dedicated system but it's
not just dedicated systems its funding
new tracks across the entire Amtrak
network the Acela which is supposedly
our high-speed rail system can only go
150 miles per hour on a small section of
track
to compare the bullet train in Japan can
reach speeds of 200 miles an hour to
make the 250 mile trip between Tokyo and
Osaka
we're decades behind our counterparts
from around the world Deborah Hersman is
president and CEO of the National Safety
Council part of this is because we don't
have a dedicated funding stream that
supports that initiative the good news
is that Amtrak has ordered 28 high-speed
trains for the Northeast Corridor with
the first of these scheduled to be in
service by 2021 the problem there are
currently no plans or the necessary
funds to build the tracks needed to
support high-speed rail
I think what's lagged is kind of the
broader issue which is investment in
infrastructure and transportation
generally that if you look across our
network we are under investing in all of
our assets those dedicated systems are
now being built some with private money
in California a high-speed rail link
between the Los Angeles area and San
Francisco is now under construction but
we'll need to be patient it won't be
finished before 2029 at the earliest but
in South Florida the nation's first
privately owned higher speed rail
project bright line is moving faster and
set for launch later this year in
Florida when bright line gets up and
running it will handle the two hundred
and five mile run between Miami and
Orlando with speeds of up to 125 miles
an hour now that's still technically not
high speed but at least while bright
line may be new it's not solving
Amtrak's problems and the continuing
need to move people by rail we have to
rebuild the infrastructure to make sure
that it stands the test of time and can
operate decades into the future our
economy is riding on the back of this
infrastructure and we've got to take
care of it
in the end it all gets down to money
Amtrak goes to more than 500
destinations across America but if the
current Trump budget plan is approved
many Amtrak officials are worried they
may have to close more than 200 stations
across America Alex Peter thanks
important story about Amtrak and
infrastructure